Because new developments are
automatically inserted in the tab order,
they can be very convenient to use.
But there are instances when you'll
want to modify the tab order.
Like if you're building a component
without a native analog,
like this dropdown up here, or if you
need to have something off screen that
should only be focusable when it
appears, like perhaps a modal window.
For these cases,
you can use the tabindex attribute.
Tabindex can be applied
to any HTML element, and
it takes a range of numeric values.
A tabindex of -1 means that the element
will not be in the tab order,
but it can be programmatically
focused via JavaScript,
by calling the element's focus method.
This can be especially useful for
off screen content which appears on
screen in response to a user event.
When the new content is displayed,
you may wish to call its focus method
which will then direct future
keyboard events to it.
A tabindex of 0 will add the element
to the natural tab order,
plus, that element will also be focus
full by calling its focus method.
For example,
here I've got a fancy button that
I've created out of just a div.
Now, without a tabindex attribute,
if I press the Tab key,
this element will not receive focus.
By adding a tabindex of zero,
now when I press the Tab key,
this element gets focused, and future
keyboard events get directed to it.
A tabindex of greater than zero, for
instance something like tab index of
5 will jump the element to the front
of the tab order regardless
of where it is in the DOM.
If there are multiple elements
with a tabindex greater than zero,
the order will start from the lowest
value that is greater than zero and
then work its way up.
In general, using a tabindex greater
than zero is discouraged and
considered a bit of an anti-pattern.
If you get in the habit of using it,
you can quickly end up with a very
jumbled tab order, and it can make
things especially confusing for
screen reader users who navigate
the DOM in a linear fashion.
Ideally, if you need to put
something earlier in the tab order,
the best bet is to
move it up in the DOM.